all right good afternoon
uh
today's speaker is peter thiel peter was
the founder of
paypal and palantir and founder's fund
and has invested in uh most of the tech
companies in silicon valley and he's
going to talk about strategy and
competition thank you for coming peter
awesome thanks uh sam thanks for
inviting me thanks for for having me uh
i i sort of have a
i have a single
e day fix that i'm completely obsessed
with in
on on the business side which is that
if you're starting a company if you're
the founder entrepreneur starting a
company you always want to aim for
monopoly and um and that uh and you want
to always avoid competition and so uh
hence uh competition is for losers uh
something we'll be talking about today
i'd like to um
i'd like to start by saying something
about
um
the the basic idea of uh when you start
one of these companies um how you go
about uh creating value and there's this
question what makes a business valuable
and i want to suggest that there's
basically a very simple uh very simple
formula that um
you you have a valuable company if two
things are true uh number one that it
creates x dollars a value for the world
and number two that you capture y
percent of x and and the critical thing
that uh that i think people
always miss in the sort of analysis is
that x and y are completely independent
variables and so um
x can be very big y can be very small
x can be of intermediate size and if y
is reasonably big you can still get a
very big business so to create a
valuable company you have to basically
both create something of value and
capture some fraction of the value of
what you've created
and sort of just to
just to illustrate uh this is a as a
contrast um
there's if you sort of compare the us
airline industry with a company like
google on search
if you sort of measure by
the size of these industries you could
you could say that airlines are still
more important than search if you just
measure it say by revenues there's 195
billion in uh domestic revenues in uh
2000 uh 2012. google had uh just north
of 50 billion um and this and so and
certainly sort of on some intuitive
level if you said uh you were given a
choice and said well do you want to get
rid of all air travel or do you want to
get rid of your ability to use search
engines the intuition would be that air
travel is something that's more
important than search and this is of
course just the domestic numbers if you
looked at this globally
airlines are much much bigger than um
than uh than than than searcher than
google is but uh but the profit margins
are quite a bit less uh you know they
were marginally profitable in 2012. uh i
think the entire hundred year history of
the airline industry the cumulative
profits in the us have been
approximately zero now companies make
money they episodically go bankrupt they
get recapitalized and you sort of cycle
and repeat
and this is reflected in you know the
the combined market capitalization of
the of the airline industries maybe uh
something um of the us airline industry
something like a quarter that of google
so so uh you have you have a search
engine much much smaller than air travel
but much more valuable and i think this
this reflects these very different uh
valuations on x and y
so um
you know if we look at perfect
competition
um you know there are sort of there's
some pros and cons to the world of
perfect competition um on a high level
uh
uh it's always um this is what you study
in econ one it's always it's easy to
model which i think is why econ
professors like talking about perfect
competition um it somehow is efficient
especially in a world where things are
static because you have all the consumer
surplus gets captured by everybody
and uh and politically it's uh what uh
what we're what we're told is good in
our society that you want to have
competition and this is somehow a good
thing um of course there are a lot of
negatives it's generally not that good
if you're you're um you're involved in
anything that's hyper competitive um
because you often don't make money i'll
come back to this a little bit later so
uh so i think at one end of the spectrum
you have uh industries that are
perfectly competitive
and at the other end of the spectrum
you have things that um i would say are
monopolies and um and
they're you know they're much stable
longer-term businesses you have more
capital uh
and um and if you get a creative
monopoly for inventing something new i
think it's symptomatic of having created
something something really valuable um
and so i do think this you know the the
sort of the the extreme binary view of
the world i i always articulate is that
there are exactly two kinds of
businesses in this world there are
businesses that are perfectly
competitive and there are businesses
that are monopolies and um there's
shockingly little that is in between and
uh this dichotomy is not understood very
well because uh people uh are constantly
lying about the nature of the businesses
they're in
and this is why this is in my mind this
is the most important it's not
necessarily the most important thing in
business but i think it's the most
important business idea that people
don't understand that there are just
these two kinds of businesses and so let
me say a little bit about the lies that
people tell
and so
you basically um the basic if you sort
of imagine that there was a spectrum of
companies from perfect competition to
monopoly
um
the the apparent differences are quite
small because the people who have
monopolies pretend not to
they will basically say uh you know and
it's because you don't want to get
regulated by the government you don't
want the government to come after you so
you will never say that you have
monopoly so anyone who has a monopoly
will pretend that they're in incredible
competition
and on the other end of the spectrum if
you are incredibly competitive
and if you're in some sort of business
where you will never make any money
um you will be tempted to tell a lie
that goes in the other direction where
you will say that you're doing something
unique um that is somehow
less competitive than it looks
because um
because you want you will want to
differentiate you want to try to attract
capital or something like that so if the
monopolists pretend not to have
monopolies the non-monopolists pretend
to have monopolies the apparent
difference is very small whereas
the real difference i would submit is is
actually quite big so there's this
distortion that happens because of the
lies people tell about their businesses
and the lies are sort of in these these
opposite direction let me let me drill a
little bit down further on the uh the
way these lies work
and so
um
you know the
the the basic uh lie you tell as a
non-monopoly is that we're in a very
small market the basic lie you tells the
monopoly is that the market you're in is
much bigger than it looks
and so um and so typically if you want
to think this in sort of set theoretic
terms you could say that a monopoly
tells um
a lie where you describe your business
as the union of these vastly different
markets and the non-monopolist describes
it as the intersection
so that uh
in effect um
if you're if you're a non-monopolist you
will rhetorically describe your market
as super small you're the only person in
that market
if you have monopoly you will describe
it as super big and um and there's lots
of competition in it so uh some examples
of how this
how this works in practice
so i always use restaurants as the
example of a terrible business there's
always you know sort of my ideas you
know capitalism and competition are
antonyms um capitalists someone
accumulates capital world of perfect
competition is a world where all the
capital gets competed away
so uh you're opening a restaurant
business no one wants to invest because
you just lose money so you have to tell
some idiosyncratic narrative and you
will say something like well we're the
only british food restaurant in palo
alto so it's british palo alto and of
course that's too small a market because
people may be able to drive all the way
to mountain view or even menlo park um
and there probably are no people who eat
nothing but british food at least no
people are still alive
and so so that is um that's that's a
sort of a fictitiously narrow market
um there's there's sort of a hollywood
version of this where uh the way movies
always get pitched is you know okay it's
like a college football star you know uh
joins an elite group of hackers
to um
to catch the shark that killed his
friend
um
sorry
and so
that's now that is a movie that has not
yet been made
but um
but
but the question is is is that the right
category or is the correct category it's
just another movie in which case you
know there are lots of those it's super
competitive incredibly hard to make
money no one ever makes money in
hollywood uh doing movies
it's really really hard
[Music]
and so you always have this question
about does the intersection does is it
real does it make sense does it have
value that one should ask and of course
there are startup versions of this where
you and the the sort of the ba really
bad versions you just take a whole
series of buzzwords sharing mobile
social apps you combine them and you
have some kind of uh narrative and
whether or not that's a real business or
not uh is is uh um is it's generally a
bad sign so it's almost this pattern
recognition when you have this rhetoric
of this sort of intersections um
it generally does not work the something
of somewhere is really mostly just the
nothing of nowhere and it's like the
stanford of north dakota
one of a kind but it's not stanford
um
so let's look at the opposite the
opposite lie
is um
if you are let's say uh the uh the
search uh company uh that's down the
street from here and has about a happy
66 market share
um
and uh is you know is completely
dominant in the search market um google
has not just
almost never describes itself as a
search engine these days um and instead
it uh it describes itself in all these
different ways so it sometimes says it's
an advertising company so if it was
searched you'd say wow that's it's like
it's it's it has this huge market share
that's really really crazy it's like a
incredible monopoly it's much bigger
than it's much a much more robust
monopoly than microsoft ever had in the
90s maybe that's why it's making so much
money
but if you uh if you say it's an
advertising market you could say well
there's search advertising is 17 billion
and that's part of
online advertising which is much bigger
and then you know all u.s advertising is
bigger
and then by the time you get to global
advertising that's close to 500 billion
and so you're
talking about three and a half percent
so um
a tiny part of this much larger market
or
if you don't want to be an advertising
company you can always say that you're a
technology company
um
and so um
sorry let me see um
and so the and and so um and and the
technology market is something like a
one trillion dollar market and uh the
narrative that you tell us google in the
in the technology market is
um well we're competing with all the car
companies with our self-driving cars
we're competing with apple on tvs and
iphones
uh we're competing with facebook we're
competing with microsoft on um on office
products we're competing with amazon on
cloud services and so we are in this
giant technology market where there's
competition in every direction uh you
you look and uh no we're not the
monopoly the government's looking for
and we should not get regulated in any
way whatsoever and so i think one has to
always be super aware that there are
these uh these very powerful incentives
to uh to distort the nature of these
markets one way or the other
so um you know the the evidence of
narrow markets in the uh in the tech
industry
is um is if you basically just uh
if you look at sort of the
some of the big tech companies apple
google microsoft amazon
um
they just um they've just been building
up cash
for um year after year and you have
these incredibly high profit margins and
i would i would say that the
one of the reasons the tech industry in
the us has been uh has been so
successful financially is because it's
it's prone to creating all these
monopoly like businesses and that's
that's um and it's reflected uh by the
fact that these companies just
accumulate so much cash they don't even
know what what to do with it beyond a
certain point um and so
so let me say um let me say a few things
about uh
about how to how to build a monopoly and
i think uh i think the
one of the sort of very
counter-intuitive ideas that comes out
of this monopoly uh thread
is that um
you want to go after small markets if
you're a startup
um
you know you want to get to a monopoly
you're starting a new company you want
to get to monopoly um
monopoly is you have a large share of a
market how do you get to a large share
of a market you start with a really
small market and you take over that
whole market and then and then over time
you find ways to expand that market in
in concentric circles and uh the thing
that's always a big mistake is going
after a giant market on on day one
because that's typically evidence that
um that you somehow haven't defined the
categories correctly that and it's it
normally means that there's going to be
too much competition in one way or
another and so i think almost all the
successful companies
in silicon valley had some model of
starting with small markets and
expanding
and you know
if you take amazon you start with you
start with you know
just um a book store we have all the
books in the world so it's it's a it's a
it's a better book store than anybody
else has in the world when it starts in
the 90s it's online there's things you
can do you can't do before and then you
gradually expand into all sorts of
different forms of e-commerce and other
things beyond that
um you know ebay you start with pez
dispensers you move on to beanie babies
and eventually uh it's it's all these
different um auctions for all these
sorts of different goods um and uh and
what was very counter-intuitive about
what's very counterintuitive about many
of these companies is they often start
with markets that are so small that
people don't think um they don't think
that they're uh valuable at all when
when you get started
um the the paypal version of this
was uh was when we started with uh with
power sellers on ebay which was about 20
000 people when we first saw this
happening in december of 99 january 2000
right after we launched there was a
sense that uh that these were all um it
was such a small market it was terrible
we thought these were terrible customers
to have it's just people selling junk on
the internet why in the world do we want
to be going after this market but um but
you know you there was a way to get a
product that was much better for
everybody in that market you could um
and we got to something like 25 30
percent you know market penetration in
two or three months and you got some
lock-in you got brand recognition and
you're able to to build the business
from there so um so i always think these
um these these very small markets are
are quite underrated uh the facebook
version of this i always give is that uh
you know the initial market at facebook
was ten thousand people at harvard it
went from zero to sixty percent market
share in ten days that was a very
auspicious start um the way this gets
analyzed in business schools is always
um that's ridiculous it's such a small
market it can't have any value at all
and so i think the business school
analysis of facebook early on or of uh
paypal early on or of ebay early on
is that the markets were perhaps so
small as to have uh almost no value and
they would have had little value had
they stayed small but it turned out
there were ways to then grow them
concentrically and that's what made them
that's what made them so valuable
um now i think the opposite version of
this is always where you have super big
markets and um and i there's so much so
many different things that went wrong
with all the clean tech companies in the
last decade but uh but
one one theme that ran through almost
all of them was they all started with
massive markets and every cleantech
powerpoint presentation that one saw in
the years 2005 to 2008 which was sort of
the clean tech bubble in in silicon
valley started with we're in the energy
market we're in a market that's measured
in hundreds of billions or trillions of
dollars
and um and then you know once you're
sort of a a minnow
in a vast ocean um that's not a good
place to be that means that you have
tons of competitors and you don't even
know who all the competitors are and so
you want to be you know you want to be a
one-of-a-kind company where it's the
only one in a small ecosystem you don't
want to be the fourth online pet food
company you don't want to be the 10th a
thin film solar panel company you don't
want to be the 100th restaurant in palo
alto your restaurant industry is a
trillion dollar industry so if you do a
market size analysis you'd include
restaurants are a fantastic business to
go into and it's often large markets
large existing markets typically mean
that you have uh tons of competition
very very hard to uh to differentiate so
the first very counter-intuitive
into uh idea is is to go after
small markets often markets that are
so small people don't even notice them
they don't think that they make sense
that's where you get a foothold and then
um and then if those markets are able to
expand you can uh scale into a a big
monopoly business
um
you know it's um a second uh sort of
there's sort of several different uh
characteristics of these monopoly
businesses um that i like to um focus on
and there's probably no no sort of
single formula to it and i i always
think that uh that in technology there's
always a sense that you know the history
of technology such that every every
moment happens only once and so you know
the next mark zuckerberg won't build a
social network the next uh uh the next
larry page won't be building a search
engine the next uh bill gates when we're
building an operating system and if
you're copying these people you're not
learning from them but it's it's and so
um there is always um these very unique
businesses that are doing something
that's not been done before end up um
end up having the potential to be a
monopoly if you're you know the the
opening the opening line in anna
karenina's that all happy companies
sorry all happy families all happy
families are alike all unhappy families
are unhappy in their own special way and
the opposite is true in business where i
think all happy companies are different
because they're doing something very
unique all unhappy companies are alike
because they fail to escape the
essential sameness that is competition
and so so one one sort of characteristic
of a monopoly technology company is some
sort of proprietary technology um my
sort of crazy somewhat arbitrary rule of
thumb is you want to have a technology
that's an order of magnitude better than
the next best thing so amazon had over
10 times as many books maybe not that
high tech but you figure out a way to
sell 10 times as many books in an
efficient online way
you know paypal the alternative for
paypal was using um was using uh uh
checks to
send money on ebay it took seven to ten
days to clear paypal could do it more
than ten times as fast so you wanna have
some sort of very uh very powerful
improvement in some um
on some order maybe an order of
magnitude improvement on some key
dimension um of course you know if you
actually come with something totally new
um it's it's
it's just like an infinite improvement
so i would say the the iphone was the
first smartphone that worked and so
that's you know that's like maybe maybe
not infinite but it's sort of definitely
an order of magnitude or more of an
improvement so i think uh the the
technology is designed to give you a
massive delta over over the next the
next best thing
i think um i think there often are
network effects that can kick in that
really help the thing that's very um and
these these lead to monopolies over time
the thing that's very tricky about
network effects
is uh they're often uh they're often
very hard to get started and so um so
even though everyone understands how
valuable they are
there's always this incredibly tricky
question why is it valuable to the first
person who's doing something
economies of scale
if you have something with very high
fixed costs very low marginal costs
that's typically a monopoly like
business and then um then there's this
thing uh of of branding which is sort of
like just uh
this idea that gets lodged in people's
brains i i never quite understand how
branding works uh so i never invest in
companies where it's just about branding
but it is i think a real phenomenon that
uh that creates uh that creates real
value i think one of the things i'm
going to come back just a little bit
towards the end but one thing that's
very striking is that software
businesses are often
are for some reason
very good at some of these things
they're especially good at the economies
of scale part because the marginal cost
of software is zero and so if you get
something that works in software
it's often significantly better than the
existing solution
and then you have these tremendous
economies of scale and you can scale
fairly quickly so even if the market
starts small
you can grow your business quickly
enough to
stay
stay at the same size as the growing
market and uh and maintain the sort of
monopoly uh power
now the critical thing about these
monopolies is um is it's not enough to
have a monopoly for just a moment the
critical thing is to have one that lasts
over time
um and so you know silicon valley is
always the sort of idea that you want to
be the first mover and i i always think
it's it's in some ways um the better
framing is you want to be the last mover
you want to be the last company in a
category those are the ones that are
really valuable microsoft was the last
operating system at least for many
decades google is the last search engine
facebook will be valuable if it turns
out to be the last social networking
site and um and one way to one way to
think of this uh last mover uh value is
this idea that most of the value in
these companies exists far in the future
um if you do sort of a discounted cash
flow analysis of a business
you look at you have sort of all these
profit streams you have a growth rate
the growth rate's much higher than the
discount rate and so most of the value
exists far in the future i did i did
this exercise at paypal in march of
2001.
we had been in business for about 27
months
and um
and we sort of had you know the growth
rate was 100 a year we were discounting
future cash flows by about 30 percent
and it turned out that about three
quarters of the value of the business as
of 2001 came from cash flows in years
2011 and beyond and um and whenever you
do the math on any of these tech
companies you get to an answer that's
something like that so if you are trying
to analyze any of the tech companies in
silicon valley airbnb twitter uh
facebook um any emerging internet
companies all the ones in y combinator
um the math tells you that
three quarters eighty eighty five
percent of the value is coming from cash
flows in years 2024 and beyond it's very
very far in the future and and so one of
the things that we always overvalue in
silicon valley is growth rates and we
undervalue durability because growth is
something you can measure in the here
and now and you can always track that
very precisely
the question of whether a company's
still going to be around a decade from
now that's actually what
what dominates the value equation and
that sort of is a much more
qualitative sort of a thing
and so if we um if we went back to this
idea of these characteristics of
monopoly proprietary technology network
effects economies of scale
um you can think of these these
characteristics as ones that exist at a
moment in time where you capture a
market and take it over but you also
want to think about are these things
going to last over time and so there's a
time dimension to all these
characteristics so network effects often
have a great time element where as the
network scales the network effects
actually get more robust and so if you
have a network effect business that's
often one that
can become
a bigger and stronger monopoly over time
proprietary technology is always a
little bit of a tricky one so you want
something that's order of magnitude
better than
the state of the art in the world today
and that's how you get people's
attention that's how you initially break
through but then um you don't want to be
superseded by somebody else and so there
are all these areas of innovation where
there was tremendous innovation but no
one made any money so you know describe
manufacturing in the 1980s
you could imp you could do a better just
build a better disc drive than anybody
else you could take over the whole world
and two years later someone else would
come along and replace yours and in the
course of 15 years you got vastly
improved disc drives so it had great
benefit to consumers but
it didn't actually help the people who
started these companies and so there's
always this question about having a huge
breakthrough in technology but then also
being able to say explain why uh yours
will be the last breakthrough uh or at
least the last breakthrough for a long
time or will you make a breakthrough and
then you can keep improving on it at a
quick enough pace that no one can ever
catch up so if you have a structure
of structure of the future where there's
a lot of innovation and other people
will come up with new things in the
thing you're working on
that's great for society it's it's
actually not that good for your business
typically
and then um economies of scale uh we've
already talked about so so i think
anyway so i think this last mover thing
is is very critical i'm always tempted
you know
i don't want to overdo the chess
analogies but you know the first mover
in chess is someone who plays white
white is about a one third of a pawn
advantage so there's a small advantage
to going first you want to be the last
mover um who who wins the game and so
this was the kappa blanca uh world
champion uh uh chess champion cava
blanca line you must begin by studying
the end game and and i do think that's
um why i wouldn't say that's the only
thing you should study i think this uh
the sort of perspective of asking these
questions why will this still be the
leading company 10 15 20 years from now
is a is a really critical one to to try
to think through
let me um
let me sort of uh i want to sort of go
in two slightly other directions with
this monopoly versus competition idea
and i think um
so i think this is the
the central idea in my mind for for
business for starting business or
thinking about them and uh and there are
so some very um interesting perspectives
i think it gives on the whole
you know on the whole history of
innovation and technology and science
because
um you know we've lived through um
we've lived through uh
you know 250 300 years of incredible
technological progress in you know many
many different domains uh you know steam
engine to railways to
telephones refrigeration household
appliances um
you know the computer revolution
aviation all sorts of different areas of
technological innovation
and then there's sort of analogous thing
that one can say about science where uh
we've lived through centuries of of
enormous amounts of innovation in in in
science as well
and um
and the the thing that i think um
people always miss when they think about
these things is um is that um because x
and y are independent variables
um some of these things can be extremely
valuable innovations but the people who
invent them who come up with them do not
get rewarded for this and and certainly
if you go back to um you need to create
x dollars in value you capture y percent
of x
i would suggest that the history of
science has generally been one where y
is zero percent across the board the
scientists never make any money um
they're always deluded into thinking
that they live in a just universe that
will reward them for their work and for
their inventions and this is probably
the fundamental delusion that that
scientists tend to suffer from in our in
our society um and and even in
technology there are sort of many
different areas of technology where um
where there were great innovations that
created tremendous value for society but
uh but people uh did not uh did not
actually capture uh that much of the of
the value and so i think there is this
sort of whole uh history of
science and technology that can be told
from the perspective of how much value
was actually captured
and um
and certainly there are entire sectors
where people didn't capture anything so
you you're the smartest physicist of the
20th century you come up with special
relativity you come up with general
relativity you don't get to be a
billionaire you don't even get to be a
millionaire um it just it just somehow
doesn't work that way
the railroads incredibly valuable mostly
just went bankrupt because it was too
much competition um wright brothers um
you fly the first plane you don't make
any money and so i think there is sort
of a structure to these industries
that's uh that's very important um and i
think the uh the thing that's actually
rare are the success cases most so it's
actually when you really think about the
history in this in this 250 year sweep
um it's unu y is almost always zero
percent it's always zero in science it's
almost always in in technology and so
it's very rare where people made money
you know the early uh the late uh 18th
early 19th century the first industrial
revolution was the textile mills you had
the steam engine you sort of automated
things and you had these relentless
improvements that people improved
efficiency of textile factories of
manufacturing generally at a clip of
five to seven percent every year year
after year decade after decade you had
60 70 years of tremendous improvement
from 1780 to 1850
but even in 1850 most of the wealth in
britain was still held by the landed
aristocracy uh the workers didn't you
know the workers didn't make that much
the capitalists didn't make that much
either it was all competed away there
were hundreds of people running textile
factories it was an industry that just
uh
the structure of the competition
prevented people uh from from making any
money
um and so i think there are in my mind
there probably are only two broad
categories in the entire history of the
last 250 years where people have
actually uh come up with new things and
made money doing so um one is these sort
of vertically integrated complex
monopolies which people
did build in the second industrial
revolution at the end of the 19th and
start of the 20th century and so this is
like ford it was the vertically
integrated oil companies like standard
oil
and what these uh vertically integrated
monopolies uh typically required was
this very complex coordination you got a
lot of pieces to fit together in just
the right way uh when you assembled it
you had a tremendous advantage this is
actually uh done surprisingly little
today and so i think this is sort of a
business form that um
when people can pull it off is very
valuable it's typically fairly capital
intensive uh we live sort of in a in a
culture where it's very hard to get
people to buy into anything that's super
complicated and takes very long to build
but i you know when i sort of think
about my colleague elon musk from paypal
success with tesla and spacex
i think the key to these companies was
the complex vertically integrated
monopoly structure they had so if you
sort of look at tesla or spacex if you
ask you know was there sort of a single
breakthrough i mean they certainly
innovated on a lot of dimensions i don't
think there was a single 10x
breakthrough
in battery storage or you know
maybe working on some things on rocketry
but they hadn't there was no sort of
single massive breakthrough but what was
really impressive was integrating all
these pieces together and and doing it
in a way that was more vertically
integrated than most of their
competitors so tesla you also integrated
the car distributors so they wouldn't
steal all the money as has happened with
the rest of the car industry in the u.s
or spacex
you basically
pulled in all the subcontractors
where most of the large aerospace
companies have single source
subcontractors that are able to sort of
charge
monopoly profits and make it very hard
for the integrated aerospace companies
to make money and so uh vertical
integration i think is sort of a very
underexplored uh modality of
technological progress that people uh
would would do well to look at more
and then i think there is there is
something about software itself that's
very very powerful um software has these
incredible economies of scale these low
marginal costs and there is something
about the world of bits as opposed to
the world of atoms where you can often
get very fast adoption and and the fast
adoption is critical to capturing and
taking over markets because even if you
have a small market if the adoption rate
is too slow there'll be enough time for
other people to enter that market and
compete with you whereas if you have a
small to mid-sized market and have a
fast adoption rate you cannot take over
this market and so and so i think this
is one of the reasons silicon valley has
done so well and why uh software has
been this phenomenal industry and what i
what i would suggest what i want to
leave you with is there are sort of
these different rationalizations people
give for why certain things work and why
certain things don't work and i think
these rationalizations always obscure
this question of i'm creating x dollars
in value and capturing y percent of x so
the science rationalization we're always
told is that the scientists aren't
interested in making money they're doing
it for charitable reasons and that
you're not a good scientist if you're
motivated by money and i'm not even
saying people should always be motivated
by money or something like this but i i
think we should we should be a little
bit more critical of this as a
rationalization we should ask is this a
rationalization um
to obscure the fact that y equals zero
percent and the scientists are operating
in this uh in this sort of world where
all the uh all the innovation is
effectively competed away and they can't
capture any of it directly and then the
uh the software distortion that often
happens is because people are making
such vast fortunes in software we infer
that this is the most valuable thing
in the world being done full stop and so
if people at twitter make uh billions of
dollars it must be the twitter is worth
far more than anything einstein did um
and um and uh and what that sort of
rationalization tends to obscure is
again that x and y are independent
variables and there are these businesses
where you capture a lot of acts and
there are others where you don't and so
and so i do think um i do think the
history of innovation has been this uh
this history where uh
the the the microeconomics the structure
of these industries has mattered a
tremendous amount and when um
and um and and and there is sort of this
this story where some people have made
vast fortunes because they were in
industries with the right structure and
other people uh made uh nothing at all
because um
because they were in these sort of very
competitive things and we shouldn't just
rationalize that way i think it's worth
understanding this better
and then finally let me come back to
this
this uh this sort of overarching theme
for this talk this competition is for
losers idea which um is always this
provocative way to to title things
because we always think of the losers as
the people who are not good at competing
we think of the losers as the people who
are um slow on the sports t on the track
team in high school or who do a little
bit less well on the standardized tests
um and don't get into the right schools
and so we always think of losers as
people who can't compete um and i want
us to really rethink and and revalue
this and consider whether it's possible
that competition itself um is off that
we we're sort of
it's not just the case that we don't
understand this monopoly competition
dichotomy intellectually so that's sort
of been talking about why why you
wouldn't understand intellectually
because um people lie about it it's
distorted we have all these
the history of innovation rationalizes
what's happening in all these very very
strange ways but i think it's more than
just an intellectual blind spot i think
it's also a psychological blind spot
where we find ourselves you know very
very attracted to competition in in one
form or another um we find it reassuring
if other people do things the word ape
already in the time of shakespeare meant
both primate and imitate and there is
something about human nature that's
deeply memetic imitative
ape-like sheep-like lemming-like
curd-like
and it's this very very problematic uh
thing that we need to always think
through and try to overcome and and
there is always this question about um
competition um as as a form of
validation where we we go for things
that lots of other people are going for
and um it's not that there is wisdom in
crowds it's not when lots of people are
trying to do something that that's proof
of it being valuable i think it's when
lots of people are trying to do
something that is often um that is often
proof of insanity there are 20 000
people a year who moved to los angeles
to become movie stars about 20 of them
make it
i think the olympics are a little bit
better because you have a
you know um you can sort of figure out
pretty quickly whether you're good or
not so it's there's a little bit less of
a deadweight loss to society um you know
um you know you're you're the sort of
educational experience at a place uh the
the pre-stanford educational experience
um there's always sort of a
non-competitive characterization i think
most of the people in this room had
machine guns they were competing with
people with bows and arrows so
it wasn't exactly a parallel competition
when you were in junior high school in
high school
there's always a question does the
tournament make sense as you keep going
and this is uh and so um there is always
this question if people go on to grad
school or post uh postdoctoral
educations does the intensity of the
competition really make sense there's
the uh the you know classic uh henry
kissinger line that uh um describing his
fellow faculty at harvard that the uh um
the battles were so ferocious because
the stakes were so small describing sort
of academia and um and and you sort of
think on one level this is a description
of insanity you know why would people
fight like crazy when the stakes are so
small but it's also i think simply a
function of the logic of the situation
when it's imp really hard to
differentiate yourself from other people
when the differences are when the
objective differences really are small
then uh you have to compete ferociously
to maintain
a difference of one sort uh or another
um that's often more imaginary than real
there's always sort of the
personal uh version of this that i i
tell where um i was sort of hyper hyper
tracked i you know my eighth grade
junior high school yearbook when my
friends wrote in you know i know he'll
get into stanford in four years
as a sophomore i sort of went into going
to stanford four years later uh the end
of high school uh went to stanford law
school uh you know ended up um at a big
law firm in uh new york uh where from
the outside everybody wanted to get in
on the inside everybody wanted to leave
um
and and you had um and it was this very
strange dynamic where after i uh sort of
realized this was maybe not the best
idea
um and i left after seven months and
three days you know one of the people
down the hall from me uh told me um it's
really reassuring to see you leave peter
i had no idea that it was possible to
escape from alcatraz which of course all
you had to do was go out the front door
and not come back but but so much of
people's identities got wrapped up in um
in winning uh these competitions that uh
they somehow lost sight of what was
important what was valuable you know
competition does make you better at
whatever it is that you're competing on
because when you're competing you're um
comparing yourself with the people
around you you're figuring out how do i
beat the people next to me how do i do
somewhat better at whatever it is
they're doing and you will get better at
that thing i'm not i'm not questioning
that i'm not denying that but um but it
often comes at this tremendous price
that uh you stop asking some bigger
questions about what's truly important
and truly valuable and so i would i
would say that uh don't always go
through the tiny little door that
everyone's trying to rush through maybe
go around the corner and go through the
vast gate that no one's taking thank you
very much
i guess it's time for
you to take a few questions or
oh yeah uh people want to take i'll take
a few questions a few minutes time
yeah go ahead um since
yeah as you mentioned earlier often
monopolies and perfect competition often
looks similar because of the narratives
people tell well now we tell ourselves
do you have any ways to easily determine
the difference when you're looking at an
idea of evaluating your own idea
well i'd say the question i always try
to focus on is what is the actual market
so not what's the narrative of the
market because you can always tell a
fictional story about a market that's
much bigger or much smaller but what is
the what is the real objective market so
it's always yeah you always try to
figure it out and you realize people
have incentives to powerfully distort
these things
yeah so which of the aspects of monopoly
that you mentioned would you say that
software like google
um
well they have uh they have network
effects with the the ad network they had
proprietary technology that gave them
the initial lead because they had the
the page rank algorithm which was uh
sort of an order of magnitude better
than any other search search engine you
have economies of scale uh
because of the need to store you know
all these different uh sites and at this
point you have brands so google has all
four
maybe maybe the proprietary technology
is somewhat weaker at this point but
definitely it had all four and maybe
three and a half out of four now
yeah how does this apply to volunteer
and second what should i
the second is what what's with the
iphone uh
oh this is that's a that's a
sort of a set of companies that are
doing different copycat payment systems
on on mobile phones or square there's
paypal sort of they have their just they
just have sort of different shapes
that's how they differentiate themselves
one is a triangle one is a square um and
so you know um
maybe at some point the apes will run
out of shapes or something like that but
um but i think um no palin's here we
started with uh focus on on
the intelligence community which is
small sub-market
you had a proprietary technology that
used a very very different approach
where it was focused on the human
computer uh synthesis rather than the uh
uh substitution which i think is the
dominant paradigm so there's a whole set
of things i would say on the on the
market approach and the uh on the
proprietary technology
uh yes
um we have design thinking methodology
and uh lean
uh startup
thinking
um which is used to mitigate risk by not
creating things that people don't want
but how do young innovators uh have
inspiration create complex systems that
last time can you review the question
yeah so the question is um what i think
about lean startups uh um iterative
thinking where you get uh feedback from
people
versus uh complexity that may not work
so i i am personally quite skeptical of
all the uh lean startup methodology i
think the the really great companies um
did something was sort of
somewhat more of a quantum
improvement that really differentiated
them from everybody else
um they did they typically did not do
massive you know customer surveys the
people who ran these companies uh
sometimes not always suffer from mild
forms of asperger's so they were not
actually that influenced not that easily
deterred by what other people thought or
told them to do um so i do think we're
we're way too focused on um iteration as
a modality and not enough on trying to
um have um you know um
a virtual esp link with the public and
figuring it out ourselves um i would say
that uh
let me see um i would say that uh
the um i'm not quite the risk question i
think is always a very tricky one
because there are um
you know there
it's not it's often i think it's often
the case that you don't have enough time
to really mitigate risks if you're going
to take enough time to figure out what
people want um you often will have
missed the boat by then um and um and
then of course there's always the risk
of of doing something that's uh that's
not that uh significant or meaningful so
you know you
you could say a track in um
in law school is a low-risk track from
one perspective it may still be a very
high risk track in the sense that maybe
you not have a high risk of not doing
something meaningful with your life so
we have to think about risk in these uh
in these very complicated ways i think
risk is for this very uh complicated
concept yes
but then doesn't that imply that there's
already competition to begin with just
on chessboard
um
yeah so there's always this uh
terminology thing so i would i would say
that uh
there are uh there are
categories in which people sort of are
bundled together i would say the
monopoly businesses
were in effect they really were a big
first mover in some sense you could say
you could say google was not the first
search engine there were other search
engines before but on one dimension they
were dramatically better than everybody
else so they were the first one with
pagerank with sort of a automated
approach
facebook was not the first uh social
networking site my friend reid hoffman
started one in 1997 they called it
social nets they already had the name
social networking uh in the name of
their company seven years before
facebook uh their idea was that it was
gonna be this virtual cyber space where
i'd be a dog and you'd be a cat we'd
have all these different rules about how
we'd interact with each other in this
virtual alternate reality facebook was
the first one to get real identity so it
was so i'd say i hope facebook will be
the last social networking site it was
the first one in a very important
dimension people often would not think
of it as the first because they'd sort
of lump all these things together
okay one more question let's take one
here uh if you're theoretically someone
who
worked at goldman sachs out of college
and left that six months and is now
studying computer science at stanford
how would you recommend rethinking
um
you know i don't i don't have a i don't
have a great um i'm not great at the
psychotherapy stuff so i don't i don't
quite know how to i don't quite know how
to uh how to solve this there are these
um you know there are these very odd
studies they've done on people who go to
um business school there's one they've
done at harvard business school where um
it's sort of the anti-asperger
um
personality we have people who are super
extroverted uh generally have low
convictions a few ideas and you have
sort of a hot house environment you put
all these people in for two years and at
the end of it they systematically end up
the largest cohort systematically ends
up doing the wrong thing they try to
catch the last wave you know in 1989
everyone at harvard tried to work for
mike milken it was one or two years
before he went to jail for all the junk
bond stuff they were never interested in
silicon valley or tech except for 99
2000 when they timed the dot-com bubble
peaking perfectly
um they did uh and then you know 05 to
07 was housing uh private equity stuff
like this so so i do think um
i do think this uh tendency for us to
see competition as validation
is um is very deep
um i don't think there's some any sort
of easy psychological formula to uh to
avoid it so i don't i don't quite know
how to uh what sort of therapy to to
recommend
but um but my my first my first starting
point which is only like it's maybe 10
of the way is to never underestimate how
big a problem it is we always think this
is something that afflicts other people
so it's easy for me to point to people
in business schools or people at harvard
or people on wall street i think it
actually does afflict all of us to a
very profound degree we always think of
advertising as things that work on other
people
how who are all these stupid people who
fall for all those ads on tv they
obviously work to some extent and they
work to a disturbing extent on all of us
and it's something we we all should work
to overcome
thank you very much
you